lexique pour lancer notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poule a alors le
pass sanitaire c'est la vedette de la
soirée at il une chance oui au nom de
passer oui clairement on a vu les
déclarations de jean castex en disant
qu'il y aura une nouvelle délibération
stanislas guérini a dit qu'il y aura un
pass oui il faut absolument qu'il y ait
un pass ce qu'il s'est passé ce soir
c'est simplement le modem qui rappelle à
la majorité présidentielle combien cette
formation politique est importante pour
la cohésion de la majorité
présidentielle pour les régionales
et pour la suite françois bayrou a peur
de disparaître dans la sphère et le
modem fait bien entendre sa voix en dix
ans attend dé nous allons débattre
certes dupas sanitaire mais surtout de
la place de la formation politique modem
dans l'avenir de la candidature des
moulins mâcon pour 2022
le pass sanitaires il faudrait qu'il y
ait un débat de bioéthique long réelle
au sein des assemblées
il n'aura pas lieu il va être fait dans
la précipitation avec l'idée bien sûr de
la vaccination et l'idée c'est de faire
une scène steve de pousser les gens à se
vacciner pour avoir ce fameux sésame qui
leur permettra de voyager d'aller un peu
partout on a vu en allemagne comment les
soudain tout est devenu ouvert pour les
vacciner l'idée c'est de faire la même
chose en france de donner envie en
disant que si vous êtes vacciné vous
pourrez aller où vous voulez grâce à ce
pas ce merveilleux même si aujourd'hui
le pass sanitaire peut exister si vous
avez un pc est négatif ou une immunité
mais il faut encadrer bien sûr la durée
encadrer le périmètre savoir combien de
temps ça va durer est ce que c'est une
mesure qui va durer dans le temps est ce
qu'on est en train d'ouvrir les portes
vers un système de biocontrôle est
dangereux pour nos libertés dangereux
pour la démocratie
ou bien est-ce que c'est simplement
quelque chose pour pousser les français
à aller se faire vacciner pour être
tranquille parce qu'on en a marre
évidemment on veut que ça ouvre mais ça
me paraît être un peu léger comme débat
parlementaire comme débats de bioéthique
de dire simplement allez vous faire
vacciner prenez un pass et n'en parlons
plus derrière il ya quand même des
questions philosophiques morale beaucoup
plus profonde que celle de se faire
vacciner le plus rapidement possible
alors le premier ministre
évidemment parler de ce déconfinement
que beaucoup attendent un déconfinement
prudent mais un déconfinement tout de
même oui alors c'est un déconfinement
compliqué on sent quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup de travail à des cabinets de
conseil que ce soit mckeen's ébène et
les autres alors il ya des dates il ya
des horaires il n'y a pas plus de 6 à
tables des terrasses avec des jauges
j'ai eu du mal à lire et à comprendre
l'ensemble de l'image en gros au 30 juin
ça devrait aller
parce que ce sera l'été et donc on verra
sachant que les masques on les gardera
jusqu'à la fin de l'été a priori mais
bon l'idée c'est de passer un été à peu
près normale avec des gestes barrières
quand même avec des gens vaccinés avec
un fameux pass sanitaires pour les
événements on parle des festivals on
parle d'événements au dessus de 1000
personnes
mais par exemple le tour de france si
vous êtes le long de la route pas de
passes sanitaire c'est en plein air tout
va bien est ce qu'un jour on va enfin
pouvoir enlever le masque en extérieur
vu qu'il ne sert pas à grand chose ça ça
n'est pas dans la loi on verra ça reste
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
questions particulièrement de la part
des commerçants on a vu combien le monde
de la nuit est inquiète les
propriétaires de boîtes de nuit qui
manifestaient qui criaient leur angoisse
et même leur colère leur désarroi en
disant nous sommes les grands oubliés
finalement de 7,2 ce déconfinement les
restaurateurs eux sont pris en compte
les aides aussi aux entreprises vont
être dégressive
mais même avec les aides mises en place
on voit bien que ça va être compliqué
pour les centres commerciaux pour les
commerces on parle de l'ouverture le
dimanche c'est aussi une façon de faire
rentrer par la petite porte l'ouverture
le dimanche
pourtant critiquée par de nombreux
syndicats en france et le manque à
gagner va rester malgré ces mesures de
déconfinement on sait bien qu'une
terrasse même si elle est élargie à 50%
ce n'est pas une terrasse à 6 à table ce
n'est pas une terrasse une salle du
restaurant qui n'ouvre pas avant le 30
juin ce n'est pas une salle de
restaurant ouverte il ya des frais fixes
il y à du personnel à payer donc ça
reste très compliqué on va dans le bon
sens
évidemment il faut rouvrir on voit que
derrière il ya la volonté d'aller plus
vite de rouvrir de passer à autre chose
même s'ils ont des conflits
alors on est quand même à plus de 4000
personnes en réanimation alors que lors
du premier des confinement en était
seulement à 2000 personnes en
réanimation donc c'est vous dire
comme finalement les jauges les chiffres
ont changé on s'adapte après tout il
faut rouvrir coûte que coûte
c'est un peu ça le quoi qu'il en coûte
alors on se souvient on assure
déconfinement à l'origine devenu premier
ministre at il appris ou bien emmanuel
macron hostile un petit peu l'agenda oui
alors c'est vrai que jean castex
il a été en charge du déconfinement
avant de devenir premier ministre
c'était à l'époque edouard philippe le
premier ministre et lui jean castex qui
gérait le déconfinement qui a été
finalement un grand lâcher prise ça a
été le virus est terminée allons-y c'est
l'été
rappelez-vous 2001 l'été c'était normal
c'était la fête est mieux là qu'on
faisait du jet ski
on était tous à la plage avait pas de
masquer les restaurants avaient réouvert
y avait pas de masque de toute façon
vous allez me dire il y avait pas de
vaccin non plus là on se rend compte que
en 2021 on a des vaccins on a des
masques on a des gestes des barrières on
a un peu appris on a aussi beaucoup de
gens qui sont animations et on se dit
qu'il va falloir être un peu plus
prudent parce qu'on entre en campagne
électorale et clairement ce choix du
calendrier depuis le début c'est madame
lac rond qui décide qui veut rester
maître des horloges contrariée avec ce
virus
le choix de faire le nom confinement en
janvier alors que nos voisins européens
considèrent en janvier en zone que nous
gagnons des jours précieux de liberté
alors avec un couvre-feu à 19 heures
avec un confinement quand même les
commerces fermés avec plus de 300 morts
par jour on est à plus de 100 106 mille
morts aujourd'hui en france on a appelé
ça gagne et de la liberté c'est beaucoup
de gens qui ont perdu en liberté ils
sont morts et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec une situation extrêmement volatile
extrêmement dangereuse si jamais la
vaccination n'arrivais pas à avoir un
effet ou être suffisante pour contrer la
propagation des variantes qui sont de
toute façon sur le territoire est là que
nous dit jean castex qu'il va falloir
écouler les doses d'astrazeneca que oui
bonjour on sait pas à paris n'ont bien
entendu on fait un bon choix que les
choix en janvier était aussi des bons
choix c'est à dire que systématiquement
avec cette majorité ils ne font que des
bons choix il n'y a pas de mea culpa ya
pas de retour sur finalement ce qui n'a
pas marché
tout va très bien dans le meilleur des
mondes et c'est grâce à aimer le
maquereau le meilleur des présidents du
monde
hamon on peut quand même se poser des
questions et se dire est ce que là on
n'est pas en train de faire un nouveau
paris et finalement de se payer un était
alors pas normal puisqu'il y aura le
passe à lithaire les jauges les gestes
barrière simplement attendre que le
prochain confinement arrive en septembre
octobre
ce serait catastrophique parce qu'on va
rentrer dans une campagne présidentielle
je pense qu'ils m'avaient maquereau en
est très conscient donc si il choisi
d'accélérer le calendrier c'est qu'il
pense que le vaccin aura son effet et
qu'il n'y aura pas de futur confinement
quitte à jouer encore davantage avec les
chiffres en faisant monter les seuils
d'alerté
que ce soit sur le nombre de cas que ce
soit sur le nombre de morts le nombre de
gens en réanimation
on voit bien que les chiffres sont
flexibles puisque ondes et confine on
confine alors que les chiffres ont
empiré depuis qu'on a confiné le mois
dernier alexis enfin il faut mieux
confie néant puisque les commerçants eux
sont très inquiet a notamment les boîtes
de nuit à titre d'exemple les quelques
mesures de compensation cela peut-il
suffire après tous ces mois de vaches
maigres voire deux pas de match du tout
d'ailleurs des mois de fermeture tout
court alors c'est ce sur quoi table
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
un énorme rebond de la consommation
quand les commerces vont réouvrir que ce
soit les restaurants mais les commerces
plus classique en disant qu'il y aura
une appétence des français à consommer
ça veut dire que la confiance serait
revenue et que on n'aurait pas une crise
sociale qui s'ancre 1 avec l'entrée dans
la précarité ou dans le chômage de
nombreux français aujourd'hui si on
regarde les indicateurs ils sont plutôt
bons à la fois sur les promesses
d'emplois à la fois sur les chiffres de
croissance le pib a été descendu
tellement bas qu'il ne peut que remonter
aujourd'hui même s'il est encore très
bas par rapport à ses niveaux d'avant
2020 donc à bercy l'optimisme est de
mise à la fois pour rassurer les marchés
les commerçants et les français la
réalité c est ce que cet optimisme va
s'ancrer dans les faits est ce que l'été
va être un été qui va permettre aux
commerces de respirer aujourd'hui les
commerces notamment dans les zones
touristiques savent très bien que ce
sera un été différent des autres avec
beaucoup moins de touristes avec des
gestes barrières avec des protocoles
ne sera pas du tout dans le cadre de
2020 ou dans les années où il n'y avait
pas de co vite donc le manque à gagner
existera et à bercy on se veut encore
rassurant en disant que les la fin des
aides sera progressive et qu'on arrivera
quand même à gérer les faillites même si
elles seront nombreuses
rappelons le il ya plus de cet habit
milliard provisionné 1 de non
remboursement du prêt garanti par l'état
pour les faillites des entreprises plus
le nombre d'entreprises aujourd'hui en
procédure de redressement et elles sont
nombreuses et les entreprises qui ont
déjà mis la clé sous la porte il suffit
d'aller dans
dans quelques villes et villages
français de voir que les pas de portes
aujourd'hui à vendre ou à louer et
certains entrepreneurs ont complètement
arrêté leur business ou préfèrent ne pas
recommencer dans des conditions
dégradées donc il faudra attendre et
voir quels sont les chiffres du 2ème et
3ème trimestre en france après l'été
pour savoir si le pari du rebond de
bruno le maire a fonctionné et si les
aides pourront sauver la majorité des
entreprises françaises
aujourd'hui sachant que les indicateurs
restent plutôt positif du côté de bercy
merci beaucoup alexis et poulain pour
cette analyse complète